استشهد فلسطيني واصيب عشرات في هجوم نفدهم
مستوطنون اسرائيليون على
مسعيه وسط الضفه وتاتي هجمات المستوطنين
التي استهدفت قرن فلسطينيه اخرى بعيد
عمليتها
المقاومه الفلسطينيه واوقعت اربعه قتل
اسرائيليين ردا على الاقتحامات
الاسرائيليه متعهده بالمزيد بالتزامن مع
دعوه اسرائيليه لعمليه واسعه في الضفه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كندا كخبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما هي السيناريوهات المحتمله
لحاله المقاومه الفلسطينيه في الضفه
الغربيه بعد تطور ادائها وقيامها بعمليات
عسكريه نوعيه وكيف استفاد المقاومون
الفلسطينيون من فشل القبضه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه ميدانيا ومن خطاب التحريض من
قبل حكومه اليمين المتطرف سياسيا في تطوير
منظومه واساليب المقاومه وجلب الاهتمام
الدولي مجددا بالقضيه الفلسطينيه وما هي
مالات الاوضاع في الضفه اثرت تهديدات
الاسرائيليه المتكرره بعمليه بعمليات
عسكريه موسعه بالتزامن مع اطلاق يد
المستوطنين للقيام بعمليات اعتداء على
الفلسطينيين وممتلكاتهم في ظل انسداد اي
افق لتسويه سياسيه شامله تعيد الحقوق
للشعب الفلسطيني على الضحك
[موسيقى]
ماذا بعد عمليتي المقاومه الفلسطينيه ردا
على الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه في الضفه
الغربيه
سؤال ترى المقاومه الفلسطينيه ان انهما
كصناع القرار باسرائيل فيه دليل على قدره
المقاومه على حيازه زمام المبادره
والتاثير في المعدلات المعادلات التي تحكم
المشهد برمته في تل ابيب تنادي القاده
السياسيون والعسكريون الى مشاورات مكثفه
مع الدعوات لرد عسكري واسع تقارير
اسرائيليه قالت ان حكومه نتنياهو تستبعد
الذهاب الى عمليه عسكريه واسعه وعميقه في
الوقت الراهن
وتقول تلك التقارير التي تداولتها وسائل
اعلام الاسرائيليه عده ان النيه تتجه في
اسرائيل الى تصعيد العمليات العسكريه خاصه
شمال الضفه وتعزيز القوات وهو ما بدا فعلا
بتعزيز القوات الاسرائيليه هناك بثلاث
كتائب اضافيه تشمل هذه القرارات ايضا
تعزيز العمل الاستخباراتي تحسبا لعمليات
اخرى ناجحه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه خاصه بعد
اعتراف الجيش باخفاقه في السباقها
استخباراتيا
بالمقابل نددت فصائل المقاومه باعتداءات
المستوطنين مشدده على انها ستقابل بمزيد
من الصمود والمقاومه وبينما يطرح المشهد
اسئله حول مساراته المقبله قال التقارير
اعلاميه اسرائيليه ان الاداره الامريكيه
نصحت حكومه نيتانياهو بعدم الذهاب في
عمليه عسكريه واسعه بالضفه
وحبره من عواقبها الامنيه والسياسيه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من تل ابيب دان
شفتان رئيس مركز دراسات الامن القومي
بجامعه
حيفا قبل ان ينضم الينا لاحقا ضيوفنا في
هذه الحلقه من رام الله ومن عمان ابدا معك
اذا شفتان
هذه
الاتجاهات او ما هي الاتجاهات السائده
حاليا داخل صناع الراي والقرار بخصوص ما
تشهده الضفه من عمليات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه طبعا ردا على الاقتحامات
الاسرائيليه
في البدايه ان اسرائيل واجهت الارهاب
لسنوات طويله وتتوقع اسرائيل ان يكون
الفلسطينيون الارهابيين ايضا لمئه سنه هذه
هي الطريقه التي يربون فيها الاطفال في
بين الفلسطينيين وهذا لن يتغير منذ ايام
الانتفاضه ولن يغير في السلوك الاسرائيلي
منذ او في كل فتره ياتي الفلسطينيون بحلول
فعاله من مثلها هذه العمليه
واسرائيل سوف تواجهها وسوف تقمع اسرائيل
العمليات الارهابيه في الضفه الغربيه
وبالتالي لا اعتقد ان الاسرائيليين لديهم
اي مشاكل بالنسبه الى المسائل الاساسيه
يعني كل هذا ياتي ردا
نعم كل كل هذا ياتي ردا على الاقتحامات
الاسرائيليه على التصعيد
الاسرائيلي
وهناك حسب
المصادر الامنيه والتقارير الاستخباراتيه
هذه الاعمال عمليات المقاومه الفلسطينيه
تاتي في ظل فشل استخباراتي اسرائيلي نقص
في المعلومات بشان ماذا تطور العبوات التي
استهدفت عربه الجيش وايضا طبيعه الكمين
الذي تم ايقاعها فيه وكذلك بشان خطط عدم
استكشاف خطط المقاومه الفلسطينيه ماذا
تقرا انت في كل هذا الفشل الاستخبارات
والامن الاسرائيلي
بالنسبه الي اخذ
الاعتبارات
التكتيكيه بعن الاعتبار ولكنني لست مهتما
بهذه الاعتبارات التكتيكيه من حيث نوع
العبوه الناسفه على المستوى الاستراتيجي
الفلسطينيون يستخدمون العنف وهذا ما قاموا
به في السابق وهذا ما سوف يستمرون بالقيام
به من بين الفتره والاخرى يمكن
الفلسطينيين ان يفاجئوا الجيش الاسرائيلي
ولكن الجيش الاسرائيلي سوف يرد على
الفلسطينيين باستخدام قوه اكثر او اقل
لقمع الارهاب طالما انك
اضع المقاطعه ولكن طالما انك تتحدث عن
الرد هناك جدل داخل اسرائيل بشان كيفيه
الرد والحسابات التي تحكم
الاسرائيلي هل بات الامر الان بيد الجيش
الاسرائيلي فقط
الجيش الاسرائيلي لديه الخبره المطلوبه
ولكن الحكومه الاسرائيليه تقرر وتتخذ
القرار بناء على الخيارات المطروحه من قبل
الجيش لدينا بعض الراديكاليين مثل بنكير
وهو مهرج ما من اخذ ما من احد ياخذه بعين
الاعتبار بطريقه جديه ما من احد يصغي الى
بن جبير او سموتتش والراديكاليين الاخرين
ولكن عندما نتحدث عن الاتجاه العام في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه والجيش الاسرائيلي
نتحدث عن خبراء
ولديه هم حلول بحسب هجمات المختلفه وسوف
يجدون الحلول لا اعتقد ان التوسع سوف يؤدي
الى احتلال اضافي للمناطق بل سوف تعزز
القوات الاسرائيليه من عملياتها لتفكيك
هذه الخلايا هذا ما قمنا به منذ اشهر وسوف
نقوم به مجددا شكرا لك
نواف عفوا لن شفتها من تل ابيب وينضم
الينا الان من نابلس نواف العامر الكاتب
الصحفي المحلل السياسي
ومن عمان ينضم الينا اللواء فايزه دويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بكما
وايضا معك فيسبوك الى اي مدى برايك افلحت
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في قراءه الاداء
السياسي
الميداني الاسرائيلي وذهابه بعيدا في
تنفيذ السياسات التحريضيه لحكومه نتنياهو
اليمينيه برايك
يعني علينا ان نعود الى عام 2020
ونعمل مقارنه ومقاربه
اين كان العمل الفدائي المسلح
المقاوم واين اصبح في عام 2020 كان هناك
29 حاله اطلاق نار في عام 2022
484 حاله وفي عام 2023
توسع اطار هذه العمليات
وتجذر واصبح اكثر شمولا وارقى نوعا
وبالتالي اكثر خطوره اصبحت المقاومه في
شمال فلسطين تحديدا ما يطلق عليها كتيبه
جنين او كتيبه نابلس عرين الاسود اصبح عمل
مقاربه منظمه
فرضت نفسها على الداخل فرضت نفسها على
الانجدد السياسيه
الاقليميه والدوليه وفرضت نفسها على
السلطه الفلسطينيه
حد ذاتها وبالتالي اصبحت رقما صعبا مع
ازدياد العمليات وازدياد الغلوب
الاسرائيلي وحكومه التطرف ازدادت العمليات
نجاعه ازدادت نجاحا نعم زادت الضريبه
ازداد عدد الشهداء مدنيين او مقاتلين ولكن
ازدادت القاعده الشعبيه
والحاظن الشعبيه لهذا لهذه الجماعات
المقاتله وبالتالي هذا النوع من العمل فهو
بصدد الانتشار الان نتحدث عن كتيبه نابلس
كتيبه جنين سنتحدث وهكذا اقرا عن كتيبه
طولكرم عن كتيبه بيت لحم عن كتيبه الخليل
وبالتالي اتساع الدائره العمل المقاومه
المنظم مبدئيا لا اقول المنظم كليا لانه
اذا دخلنا في هذا المجال يجب ان يكون
العمل بمجمله منظم سواء كان في جنين او في
نعم اسعد الله اوقاتكم لا شك ان المقاومه
هي فكره والفكره لا تموت
الدليل على ذلك ان يعني ما تفضل به
الاستاذ الدويري واضيف عليه يعني
ان العمل المقاوم في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
وتحديدا بالضفه الغربيه شهد في الشهر
الفائت سجل 1500 عمليه او عمل مقاوم ضد
الاحتلال شكل 513 منها بمعنى نصف 50% منها
في شمال الضفه الغربيه العمل الفلسطيني
المقاوم الاصل هو ان تفهمه القياده
السياسيه انه سند للفعل السياسي لان العمل
العسكري الذي لا يقود سياسي طبعا سيكون
انتحار ولذلك المقاومه لابد ان تكون
مقاومه راشده تدرك ماذا تفعل واين تسير
واذا مدى ترمي
المقاومه الفلسطينيه حتى اللحظه استطاعت
ان تفشل مخططات لاحتلال في شمال الضفه
الغربيه
هل تراها تتحرك بغطاء سياسي كما كما تقول
الان
طبعا لا يعني
المشروع السياسي او مشروع التسويه لا يقف
قدماه على على مشروع المقاومه لذلك ترى
السلطه والقائمين على مشروع التسويه ان
العمل المقاوم والمقاومه هي فكر مناقض
لفكرتها في التسويه وتراها تشكل خطر على
مشروعها ومشروعيتها وبالتالي الاسرائيلي
عندما يفكر بعمليه يقول ان احدى المحاذير
من عدم القيام بشن عمليه عسكريه في شمال
الضفه او الضفه هو عدم اضعاف السلطه
الفلسطينيه بمعنى انهم يريدون ان تبقى
نعم
بالمقاومه ان تنشا وان تنمو وان تتقدم
فقدنا يعني
حاضنه الشعبيه التي يستهدفها المستوطنين
هذه الايام اعود الى كفاية يعني اذا كان
هذا الغطاء السياسي او الحاضنه السياسيه
ليست موجوده بالشكل المطلوب
ولن تكن واقعيين يعني ما السقف الذي يمكن
ان تصل اليه او تتحرك في ظله المقاومه
الفلسطينيه غير عبوات وهجمات وكفى
لا يعني العمل المقاوم قد يبدا بطريقه
عشوائيه او بطريقه فرديه ولكن يحقق النضج
مع تطور العمليات علينا ان ننظر الى
الخارطه الفلسطينيه في عام
2021 معركه سيف القدس برج على الساحه
الفلسطينيه داخل فلسطين ما اطلق عليه او
اطلقت عليه رؤوس المثلث غزه الضفه عربي
الداخل اصبح هناك نوع ما لا اقول من
التلاحم ولكن نوع من التعاون حتى امتد الى
داخل الخط الاخضر بمعنى ان العمل المقاوم
يحتاج الى قيادات سياسيه ناضجه سياسات
وطنيه واضع اكثر من خط احمر تحت كلمه
وطنيه لماذا لان العمل المقاوم كما تتحدث
ضيفك هو ضد توجه السلطه الفلسطينيه
ذهاب اسرائيل الى عمليه موسعه احد اسبابه
المانعه انه يمكن ان يؤدي الى اسقاط
السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ما يميز هذا
العمل الان لاحظي اذا اخذنا كمثال كتيبات
جنين او عرين الاسود الافراد الذي ينضوا
ضمن هذه المجموعه لا ينتموا الى طيف
سياسيا واحد هناك من حركه من سرايا القدس
هناك من عز الدين القسام وهناك من شهداء
الاقصى اي بمعنى اخر نجد مقاتلين الجهاد
حماس فتح موجودين في عرين الاسود في نابلس
موجودين في كتيبه جنين هذا التنوع والخروج
من عباءه الفصائليه هذا يحتاج الى ترشيد
ويحتاج كما قلت الى قاده لديهم القدره
السياسيه والاداريه على اداره وضبط ايقاع
هذه العمليات وان يوحدوا الجهود في في عمل
تكاملي وهذا يحتاج الى وقت ويحتاج الى
اسبابها هل هذا ممكن
لم اسمع السؤال
هل هذا ممكن
توحيد الجهود السياسيه غير ممكن في
عمليا يعني لا يجب ان نوفل على ان مشروع
التسويه السياسي التي تقف على راسه في
الساحه الفلسطينيه السلطه ومنظمه التحرير
لم يكن خيارا شعبيا ولا خيارا وطنيا ولا
خيارا فصائل انما كان خيارا يعني لتنظيم
واحد او لقوه واحده مدعوم
وبضغوطات اقليه على وجه الخصوص وضغط دولي
حتى تكون الفرصه مهيئه
لتمرير عمليه تسويه يدفع فيها الطرف
الضعيف الفاتوره الباهظه من الاثمان تفرض
عليه كل اشكال الضغوطات حتى في مسارات
التعليم التي يذهب الاحتلال فيها الى ابعد
مدى عندما تتاح للطالب الاسرائيلي في
المدارس ان تكون الطبشوره على شكل رصاصه
والقلم على شكل الصاروخ حتس بينما يحضى
هذا الفلسطيني ان يتحدث عن المقاومه في
مناهجه التعليميه ولهذا فان الذهاب الى
موضوع يعني التناغم السياسي في موضوع
المقاومه ودعم المقاومه يعني
بعيد جدا في هذه المرحله على الاقل بحكم
الضغوطات الاقليميه المحيطه بينما يذهب
الشارع الى المزيد من دعم المقاومه وتذهب
السلطه الى مزيد من الضغط على المقاومه
بكافه الاشكال المتاحه لها سواء الملاحقات
نعم عند فكره قالها قبل قليل الاستاذ فايز
الدويري وهي انه ما يحكم قرار اسرائيل
بالذهاب الى عمليه عسكريه واسعه هو الحرص
على عدم اسقاط السلطه الفلسطينيه في رام
الله
طبعا يعني هذا مهم جدا ويدركه الفلسطيني
ويدركه السياسي ويدركه يعني الاقليم لان
السلطه الفلسطينه وذهبنا الى الى الى
مواضيع ومحاور اتفاقيه سنجدها في نهايه
المطاف هي سلطه وظيفيه وحتى اتفاقيات
باريس الاقتصاديه يعني احكمت الخناق على
الموارد الماليه التي تاتي الى السلطه
الفلسطينيه وبالتالي السلطه يعني
في الحاله هذه هي التي تتلقى الضغوطات
وتتلقى التعليمات او الاوامر بشكل او باخر
صحيح انها ليست تعليمات يعني ان لم يعني
جانب نصاب في هذا الوصف لكن السلطه
الفلسطينيه من الضعف ما يجعلها ترفض
الذهاب بشكل او باخار الى التلاقي معقول
المقاومه والدليل هو الرفض التام لكل
لقاءات المصالحه واخرها كانت في الجزائر
طيب نحاول ان نستشر في الدقيقتين
الاخيرتين
دويري مقالات الاوضاع في
الضفه ما التطورات الميدانيه التي يمكن
توقعها في المرحله المقبله مع عوده القصف
الجوي واطلاق يد المستوطنين وتعهد
المقاومه باستمرار عملياتها الميدانيه
ماذا تتوقع هناك عده هناك عده طروحات يتم
تداولها اولا
الجهاز العسكري الجيش الاسرائيلي حتى هذه
اللحظه هو من يتحفظ على شان عمليه واسعه
النطاق في شمال فلسطين في شمال الضفه
الغربيه بينما
الاطار السياسي وزير الماليه
وبنكفير يدعموا نتنياهو يتردد اذا هناك
انقسام داخل البيت السياسي
الشينبيت يؤيد
بالتصعيد وليس بالعمليه الواسعه لكن هناك
موانع تحول دون ذلك في البعد الاسرائيلي
كما قلت لا يوجد اجماع وفي البعد
الفلسطيني وفي البعد الامريكي في البعد
الامريكي لا شارون موجود ولا بوش موجود
ولا
برج التجاره على مرمى اقل من عام يضاف الى
ذلك في الب داخلي اولا اي عمليه واسعه قد
تفضي اما الى مزيد من انهاك واضعاف السلطه
او الى اسقاطها وبروز البدائل ما هي
البدائل البديل حماس البديل الجهاد البديل
المعارضين والمناويين من فتح وبالتالي
اجد ان ان الذهاب الاسرائيلي سيكون بتوسيع
اطار العمليات والاغتيال
نواصل العامر كيف ترى مستقبل هذه العمليات
باختصار شديد لو سمحت
اختصار شديد العمليه المتوقعه هي اقل من
السوره الواقي واكثر من كاسر الامواج معنى
انها ستكون بمنزله بين المنزلتين بحيث لا
تدفع يعني اسرائيل يعني الثمن من في
الواقع السياسي في الساحه الفلسطينيه
بانقلاب الاوضاع الى ما لا تحمد عقباها
على اعتبار ان البديل كما ذكر الاستاذ
ضيفكم الاخر في عمان ان البديل الاخر هو
قوه المقاومه شكرا جزيلا لك الاستاذ نواف
العامر الكاتب الصحفي كنت معنا منه عمان
عفوا من نابلس وشكرا لفيز الدويريا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من عمان
شكرا لكما الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج مهراء الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]